[Music]
kids may be small but they are more
powerful than you think
in fact kids have superpowers that would
astonish most adults we found some
pretty interesting kid and baby facts
that had us cheering for these
superhumans if you are new to the things
make sure to subscribe and like our
video now here are ten superpowers all
kids are born with toddler telepathy
did you know toddlers can read minds
they can tell what you're feeling
researchers at the University of
Washington were stunned when they
discovered that 18 month olds engage in
what they call emotional eavesdropping
they say these little mind readers
listen and watch emotional reactions
directed by one adults to another and
then use this emotional information to
shape their own behavior they concluded
that this may be a precursor to reading
other people's minds by understanding
their emotional and psychological states
a psychology professor involved in the
study was fascinated with house into the
toddlers our to the emotional dynamics
of the interactions around them she said
they don't even need to try how to
behavior of their own and get rewarded
or punished they can watch what someone
else does and learn from what happens to
them kids are basically like lightning
rods for emotions they pick up
everything around them and use it to
their advantage
it's how they learn about the world
around them and can be used as a tool
for survival for instance if a child's
mom is afraid of snakes her baby will
see that fear and know to stay away from
snakes
pretty cool huh supervision if we were
to show you a picture of two cute
monkeys side-by-side would you be able
to tell them apart well babies can we
all could when we were six months old
according to a new study babies have got
Google beat with their face recognition
skills researchers showed babies
pictures of two similar looking monkeys
and they were able to distinguish the
facial features in the individual
primates while adults could not this
also applies to human faces babies have
an amazing ability to remember every
feature of a face after seeing it only
once we all lose this superpower over
time apparently when your brain starts
putting labels on the things it sees it
limits your ability to distinguish
subtle differences since the Language
Center in the Bay
brain is developing they can see and
process even the slightest details in
faces and objects take a look at these
three snail pictures which of the two
are similar
most of us would guess that a and B are
the same right but babies correctly
perceive B and C as similar even though
the glossy shine from the light is
different
Trippi baby dog whisperers
move over Cesar Millan because babies
are the new dog whispers check this out
babies can decipher the different
meanings of dogs barks whoa scientists
say that infants can match the sounds of
an angry snarl and a friendly Yap to
pictures of a dog displaying threatening
and welcoming body language in an
experiment they showed babies two
different pictures of the same canine
one wasn't an aggressive stance and
another was in a friendly stance then
the researchers played the clips of
friendly and aggressive dog barks the
babies always stared at the appropriate
picture to match with the bark tone this
probably comes from our caveman days
when kids had to detect whether or not
that saber-toothed tiger was going to
have them for lunch babies can also
detect whether someone is speaking in
their native tongue or not by watching
videos without any sound they can tell
just by watching the movement of
people's faces if they are speaking a
different language because of this
incredible ability they are able to
effortlessly learn any of the world's
languages can you do that you could when
you were six months old don't feel too
bad about it you can still be any baby
in a foot race internal furnaces did you
know that babies can't shiver it's
physically impossible so how does a tiny
human who can't shiver can cover herself
up and can't seek shelter from colder
temperatures stay warm the answer is
something called brown fat it's like an
internal heating blanket that burns
super hot inside the body to keep the
baby warm this fat is also present in
hibernating animals who need to stay
warm during the long winter snooze in
newborn babies brown fat makes up about
5% of their bodies it's usually found
around the neck and shoulders
scientists are freaking out about this
because they think this information
could be used to fight obesity in adults
as we get older our brown fat
away and we end up with its lazy cousin
white fat white fat just lounges like a
couch potato in your body and doesn't
help you to stay as warm as the
healthier fats scientists are trying to
find a way to activate the growth of
this super baby fat in adults so they
can lose weight and stay healthy as well
as snuggly warm so to all you young
folks watching don't be so quick to lose
that baby fat superhuman strength have
you ever seen a baby wrap its tiny hand
around its moms fingers this reflex is
called the palmar grasp reflex and
babies can do it in the womb here's
what's crazy about this reflex it is
strong enough to hold a baby's entire
body weight this is one of the first
things they checked when a baby is born
to be sure she is healthy and strong
anyone who has held a baby and had the
unfortunate experience of having them
grab your hair and knows the power of
those tiny hands at around four or five
months babies start to lose this reflex
and start being able to voluntarily pick
items up with their hands this combined
with their super perception supervision
and hyper hearing abilities makes for a
phenomenon of super babies we can't wait
for the movie studios to pick up on this
one can you say infants Avengers baby
justice Lee babies just might be able to
give Hulk a run for his money in
strength and temper tantrums
super healing powers here's a pretty
cool discovery we found babies actually
have the ability to heal their mothers
from inside the womb according to NPR a
German scientist discovered that fetal
cells circulate throughout the mother's
body for years after pregnancy they go
around healing the mother and making
sure she was strong so she can raise the
little one after he is born in scars
left by c-sections scientists found
fetal cells that make collagen to help
the scar heal so even after the baby is
born the mom can benefit from the
leftover fetal cells in the moms body
these super cells are pretty amazing
they have been linked to a decreased
risk in rheumatoid arthritis and breast
cancer this part is going to blow your
mind
they discovered that if a mother suffers
from organ damage the fetus can send
stem cells to help her regenerate organ
tissue Nature
has allowed for unborn babies to save
their mothers lives these superpower
cells they share with their mom can
graft into tissues including bone marrow
which could possibly provide a lifetime
supply of super baby cells to help Mom
replace damaged ones it makes sense that
babies would be able to make sure their
mother is around and healthy enough to
care for them super taste with all these
other super abilities you probably won't
be surprised to learn that babies have
an incredible sense of taste this
superpower is due to the fact that they
have three times the amount of taste
buds as adults do these taste buds cover
their tongues tonsils palates and cheeks
this could be the reason babies and
toddlers are such picky eaters but
mothers could change that by eating a
wide variety of foods during pregnancy
studies have shown that the taste of
whatever foods the mother eats while
pregnant transfer to the amniotic fluid
which the baby drinks mothers who drank
carrot juice every day during pregnancy
for example had kids who preferred
carrots after they were born babies and
kids from all backgrounds tend to prefer
sweet foods this is because they need a
lot of extra energy from sugars to grow
all babies seem to hate vegetable stems
because of their bitterness that bitter
taste has the intensity of poison in
their mouths
no wonder babies can be so dramatic when
they don't want to eat food they don't
like they really might believe those
Brussels sprouts are poison
superintelligence babies brains grow at
a phenomenal rate in the first three
months of a child's life her brain grows
by 64 percent it goes from being about
one-third the size of an adult brain to
half the size of an adult brain in
ninety days inside that massive baby
brain they have the same number of
neurons as an adult about 86 billion in
that time of rapid mine growth they form
the connections between these neurons
are called synapses and they form every
time the baby learned something new by
the time they turn into brainy toddlers
they have formed 1,000 trillion synapses
as they get older the brain weeds out
the unnecessary connected in a process
called synaptic pruning the cerebellum
which is part of the brain that is
responsible for motor development by
grabbing objects and crawling is the
fastest-growing region of the brain in
contrast the hippocampus which helps
form memories grows at the slowest rate
that explains why none of us remember
being babies it's probably for the best
toddler world domination would be so
messy super sense of justice we've all
probably heard kids shout the popular
phrase no fair right that common protest
stems from the fact that babies seem to
have an innate ability to sense fairness
and justice at a very early age one
study showed that 15 month olds notice
unequal distributions of food and drink
researchers believe that this sense of
fairness is connected to their own
willingness to share how did they figure
this out well they had the children
watch movies of someone distributing
food either equally or unequally most of
the toddlers spent more time focusing on
the unequal outcome this led the experts
to believe that the toddlers were
surprised that it violated their basic
sense of fairness they also prefer those
who they find to have higher morals in a
study at Yale University babies were
shown a puppet show and then asked if
they preferred the nice puppet or the
mean puppet even though the puppets
looked identical the babies reached for
the nice puppet and avoided the mean one
researchers concluded that this showed a
baby's ability to evaluate the
difference between good and bad just
like Superman limb regeneration we
couldn't believe this one but it's true
did you know that if a baby loses a
fingertip she has the ability to grow a
new one in its place
amazing right according to scientists
children can sometimes regrow the tip of
an amputated finger as long as there's a
bit of a nail left over and the wound
isn't stitched up
apparently there's a population of stem
cells lying beneath the base of the nail
that can help your body regrow a
partially amputated digit but only if
there is enough of the super stem cells
left and the tissue found under the nail
this process is common with amphibians
but when we are young we also have this
super ability and that's not all kids
also have super bone healing
capabilities when you're young your
bones are generating faster than it can
be replaced so in a way kids bones are
always behaving as if they are healing
since
their bones are already engaged in a
supercharged rate of growth bones heal
in about half the time it takes for
adults Wow
and that's it for ten superpowers all
kids are born with thanks for watching
the things see you next time
[Music]